tonight on Kitchen
Nightmares Gordon heads to Sunny South
Florida but ends up in a gloomy
situation has a business ever worked in
9 years no at a restaurant called Leist
don't you dare go to the wrong table in
spite of the business failing miserably
I don't get it you don't have to get it
this Chef owner still operates like a
stubborn dictator quiet quiet quiet who
doesn't listen to anybody I'll do what
the [__] I like not his employees Alex
this is yours fault you sort it out not
his wife where you going get back here
youve [__] up enough tonight and not
even his customers he wants to Mee R
time go [__] himself you know tonight
Gordon is in for the match of the year
it's like a competition between you and
I you don't intimidate me but he is not
backing down treat your wife like a
[__] dog don't you [__] go I'm
going to do it get ready for a
head-to-head confrontation why can't you
just cook it as Chef Ram the attempts to
get through to a man so arrogant I don't
know if you're part of hearing and so
resistant to change there's one person
cooking that's me that his restaurant
may be impossible to rescue you are
blatantly ignorant that's tonight on
Kitchen
Nightmares
Lighthouse Point an exclusive Community
6 mil outside of boa ratan Florida lined
with large Mansions Christine beaches
and home to
leistra after studying at top Michelin
star restaurants throughout Europe Andy
trusdale met and married the love of his
life Ellen come on give me a kiss see
you see you later Andy and I met and St
Thomas at the restaurant that he was
executive chef and I fell in love with
his food it was love at first
bite I've worked in a chef in many
different areas in big hotels small
hotels little restaurants and I can run
rings around anyone
anyone tired of working for other people
they moved to South Florida in 2001 to
fulfill Andy's dream of opening up a
restaurant of his own good evening the
beach to restaurant can I help you
hello hello my s decided to buy a
restaurant because she obviously tried
my food she realized how dedicated I was
and I'm very on the ball with everything
hey what's that [__] over there get off
the shelf get that off there andy is not
only a chef he's a Creator don't forget
my apples you need apples cut three nice
rings I would really say he's a master
at what he does and if I didn't think my
husband was a brilliant Chef I would not
be in this business with him Alan
I'm right
here table 14 is ready for the entree
I'm going to run this now there seems to
be a lot of wealth in the area but for
some reason the people that live in
Lighthouse Point do not seem to
appreciate Andy's food Andy they didn't
want they don't want anything else it's
Drew dry the problem is he think he's
perfect so he really don't like it when
people send back to food steak is
Grizzly get the [__] out out of here
that's beautiful beef talin they're a
local customer I don't give a [__] they
were in here the Alex this is your fault
you sort it out my food it's perfect
I've worked long and hard and PID for
the right to have what I want be quiet
whether people come and like it love it
or hate it it's my business it's my
reputation it's my food I'm the chef and
I'm the owner that's what I
[Music]
want I really wish I knew what the major
problem with liistro was I I can't say
it's the food of course I can't say it's
me I don't believe it's my
staff I just don't know what the problem
is be happy don't
be it's a beastro it's fun it's upbeat
right now I can't keep up with the
debt and I don't know where we're going
to get the money to pay the debt off
it's going from bad to worse for the
work and the effort and everything we're
do and everything we put into this would
definitely not benefit anything if this
restaurant closes last thing I want to
do is go and work for some idiot
somewhere
else I hate
[Music]
idiots South Florida known for many
great things great beaches water sports
and a place where people like to dine
out liistro is Chef owned and he's on
his ass now today he's close for lunch
cuz he's holding a cooking class I'm
about to pay him a surprise visit here
we go uh the menu is a goat shese that
we have on the menu um we put a little
be poen on you arrange it so it looks
like a
flower oh hi hello good afternoon hello
ladies gentlemen good afternoon nice to
see you please don't let me stop you how
are you yeah no problem nice to meet
yeah very don't look very happy what's
matter uh just right in the middle I'm
oh right okay the first impression I had
when Gordon Ramsey walked in the door
was what the [__] is he doing here so
what's wrong Trey Chef I just thought
we' do like a little minute take a
little sine nice Hello nice to meet you
nice to you here and you're the server
uh she's my wife oh she's your wife oh
nice lucky lady so maybe like a large
dice bring them up to the boil let them
simmer for about 15 minutes going to put
a little bit of butter in
there should it be
smoking so that's okay you obviously
just play a little smoke
[Music]
um I felt the Gordon Ramsey was just
being an
actor thank you very much hope you
enjoyed it nice to see you so much thank
you very much thank you so how do you
think that went happy with it uh not
really what's the matter those cooking
classes go very very well for us I don't
want you to [__] it up to try and make a
mockery of what I'm doing in front of
these people Jesus are you always like
this or always like what so defensive
you ask me a question I'm answering
[Music]
you okay so let's lineen up a little bit
come over Johny please so where did you
start cooking Andy I'd work for uh
Michel R in London you work for Michel r
at the water sign in yeah that's exactly
what happened to me so we had a very
similar sort of training honestly from a
chef point of view You' you've got your
stripes so in your mind the one single
reason to why the ran is not working
Ellen will be what for some reason
people don't find it appealing to come
in here and I mean the locals where are
bread and butter clientele don't seem to
enjoy the restaurant they're not biting
people really and
truly are pretty
demanding think we're fed up with
it has a business ever worked in 9 years
no never it's gone up and down it's
never been great Andy ell said your dear
wife said very quickly no if it's never
works don't be embarrassed I'm not but
I'm just saying that she's
wrong right I'd like I'd like to eat
seen the cooking class fantastic resume
and I'd love to taste your food and yeah
show off Show Me What You're Made Of
just take it off the menu
yeah I don't know what Chef Ramsey is
going to say because Andy's food is very
good and he somehow manages to stay
ahead of the trends all the time with
his menus and his recipes
just as we always do that's not changing
nothing we don't have two or three
people cooking on the stove it's me on
the stove listen you got to hand me that
[__] out of that fridge we no [__]
around if I say I want it this way I
want it that way because I say I've
earned it I'm paying for it okay just a
minute for the lamb and we're going to
have everything else going right out
nice to meet you that good to see
[Music]
Gordon Alex do your job let's go okay oh
he is the rette H do PT thank you you're
welcome
Jesus I think I just chipped my tooth
didn't look like Duck cartilage Christ
show him the bone as well
Jesus I just bust my tooth here man he
found the bones on his duck listen go
away go away he doesn't listen to nobody
that's it that's the way he is cannot
change Andy
Alex
Jesus coconut curry jalapeno my God
garlic coconut lamb inside the it is
okay uhhuh did you show Chef the college
yeah I did he uh told me to like go go
away he didn't want to talk about it
that's the
[Music]
truth so rubbery huh the texture of the
Lamb it's just very
rubbery but it's ianian crispy fried
lamb Curry roll I'm in Florida not in
Mumbai you he it whatever this is
[__] this is just to [__] us up no
that's not why whatever I'd stop right
there I you and go away Gordon Ramsey
trashed everything I did I think that's
his whole goal is to [__] all over you
make you feel
bad okay uh right that was interesting
so that was you at your best that my
best I've ever done in my career you
mean the best here or do you mean is
that the best food that we have yes I
know I mean you know was that I asked
you to cook for me and just yeah just
tell me how that was for you that was
good for this restaurant it's good for
[Music]
him here's the problem the food's
oldfashioned and totally totally out of
text in terms of where you are that's
your
opinion the food is sad stuck in the 80s
possibly the most shocking Dish anywhere
in Florida the crispy lamb roll what in
the hell was going on when we put that
one Together Trey coconut horrible
rubbery texture almost on the verge of
being
[Music]
depressing any more you want to put me
down
for the briet I don't know if anyone
give you feedback but it was on the
verge of breaking my tooth all right I'm
supposed to believe that you're not
looking at me now as if I'm exaggerating
was full of colage I'm listen to what
you're saying nobody I didn't know no
one told me no one told you hey man he
found the bones on his dir doesn't go
away two second sir yeah did you not
tell the chef that the first mouthful
was full of
cartilage yeah I did me I told him he
told me to go away when your waiter
comes to tell you valuable information
you should know those kind of things
right can I just have two minutes with
Andy my own would you mind Ellen would
you
mind honestly yeah straight up I'm here
to help so far all you doing is just
slam me down that's all you've done with
me I think it's about you don't blame me
I know you are
yeah he's not my chef he's not we don't
work for him you're the chef owner right
so why won't you take responsibility I'm
the chef you don't like it that's fine
it's your opinion you don't like it
we're [__] we're no good I'm lousy
whatever [__] me do you have
issues coming up Andy is ready to make a
confession I'm a loser everybody but
that doesn't mean he is ready to change
go back and tell her choose something
else Madness as he continues to battle
with the patrons T go [__] himself the
weight staff get back here you've [__]
up enough tonight and Chef Ramsey don't
you [__] go there don't point that
[__] I'll what [__] I like that's
next on Kitchen
Nightmares in the short time that Chef
Ramsey has been at liistro he is already
feeling very uncomfortable with the
Arrogant owner that cooked the food you
don't like it we're [__] we no good
I'm lousy whatever now it's time to see
how this tiny South Florida restaurant
handles its customers in a dinner
service I got to take the order and they
come to you
okay I'm the only one who takes the
order it's a joke many waers are
actually working one is that purpose or
is that the way they do it I would love
to be able to just take the orders but
Andy only wants one person writing the
checks thank God he brought the bre
seriously is Alex the only one to take
orders in there yes one person takes the
orders and it slows down things for Andy
I've just noticed two tables that are
waiting to get their order taken okay
I'll go out and see what's
happening Hi how are you Hi awesome yay
do you know what you like okay who would
like to start oh my
[Applause]
God so what you do usually pull out
everything when he calls an order on so
he can get it on the fire so do you
actually cook as well or not I can but
he does not let me
cook this is definitely his little
kingdom here isn't it his little onean
band hey hey hey we don't have time for
talking I don't care if it's him or the
queen Jesus just keep going over that
refrigerator you look on there and go
over everything
[Music]
wow who is this writing that's me why
because why are you doing that you're
going against everything we said and
everything we did I'm sorry where you
going get back here you [__] up enough
tonight people are really dumb sometimes
and they think with their ass rather
than their brain it's an hour into
dinner service and this part Chef part
dictator has now allowed a few Entre to
leave his kitchen Andy am I ready to
take this been waiting for you yeah the
fries are there I don't know what you
want me to do that goes on the plate
Madness are you g hi thank you for your
patience it's it's inedible medium well
done it's really too red for me I like
it well but not short I know okay thank
you Andy she wants it well but not
charred the ask medium well that's meum
well she wants it more I don't care
we're not doing it again no so go back
and tell her choose something else oh je
Houston we have a
situation I'm very sorry but the chef
you like you to make a different
[Music]
choice this is unbelievable CU there's a
lot of similarity between Andy and I
we're both English and we both studied
in Paris but there's one thing we don't
share in common I care about my
customers here clearly doesn't give a
[__] what a
[Music]
shame and here I say he terrible was
terrible about it he wants to meeting R
time go [__] himself you
know why you looking for excuses and
every [__] table that's came back all
you want to do is argue with them look
at the potatoes they're black so [__]
sad well all you've done is slammies the
second you've been here that's what you
do right why are you acting like this I
don't get it you don't have to get
it Andy seriously you don't give a [__]
big boy you're looking for a
justification every time you [__] up a
man that can't even accept his own
mistakes or get you started wipe your
ass say it's brilliant Chef you're
amazing treat your wife like a [__]
dog don't put my wife into it I'm going
to do it do you know why don't bring my
[__] wife into it don't you [__]
go there don't point that [__] Fu
life well just calm down I just ask
politely don't talk to her like that cuz
you haven't got respect for her how can
you get people working for you yeah
whatever this is
[__] byebye after getting nowhere
with Andy in the kitchen just you leave
would you be so kind just to fill out
these customer comment cards sure Gordon
steps outside not only to cool off but
to get some feedback from the clientele
let's go something Andy has never done I
asked your customers leaving the
resturant thece me to rate the service
out of 10 to rate the food to rate the
experience so on average 4 out of 10 for
the
service on that note why do you take all
the tables order that's what they want
who oh me so what's the rational behind
it the logic it helps to space a little
bit buy a few minutes there's three of
you in the kitchen like I said I don't
know if you're hard of hearing but
there's one person cooking that's me
food they rated three out of 10 but the
most important question was would they
come
back and about 78% of them said no and
the weird thing about the whole service
tonight every time something comes back
as far as you're concerned your
customers are wrong no that's your
evaluation that's what I
watched don't make you right and me
wrong about every single thing oh my God
why you have to be a [__] [__] cuz
you act like such a dick every time
[__] it's like a a competition
between you and I you don't intimidate
me what bully me that's all you're
trying to [__] do you're so wrapped
up in a deluded little bubble and not
one person has got the balls to tell you
the truth it's not working you are
blatantly ignorant whatever [__] you
come on well you're one-sided that's all
you want to [__] do man excuse me
hold
no it was a miserable evening in which
Chef Ramsey tried continually to get
through to Andy that's your evaluation
oh my God but this stubborn Chef flat
out refuses to listen just don't want to
get better to you what you've never ever
ever understood the value of your
customers let alone your
staff because you don't give a [__]
about
them I'm a loser
everybody I'm the worst
[Music]
God anything else I got any more guys
can you give me 2 minutes on my own
please
guys can you just back off
[Music]
please would you mind yeah everybody
everybody
out a doing it who's an [__] we can
never tell him that cuz he won't listen
he won't listen to nobody do you want
your restaurant to work yes or no
obviously yes okay good but stop there
that's the most honest you've been all
day I told you that you don't need to be
so defensive with me tonight was about
observing and watching the [__] setup
you have created a monster here what are
you suggesting are you committed to
making this place change that's all I
need to know before I'm out of here that
that is it yeah you can change
everything and no no I need to hear it
from I you you you you you Andy you
thank you I'll see you in the morning
good night get some sleep [__] me [__]
you now gentlemen good night one
stubborn [__] huh
Andy's statement that he has opened to
change has kept Chef Ramsey around for
at least another day but Gordon is fully
aware that he is at the beginning of a
huge uphill battle take a seat sit down
and relax how cool is this terrific
right I wanted to come out and clear the
air because of the stigma and your
training and the proudness that's
defense mechanism but before we start
changing you have to understand that we
have to identify the problems with the
restaurant you've got to understand
where you've gone wrong and when you
come downstairs me I got a little
surprise for you sandwich would be nice
sandwich [__] now stop thinking about
your
tummy now come down because in this door
okay I've arranged for you to meet yeah
some very special
people good morning ladies and gentlemen
how are we good to see you in this room
are are your previous customers and
they've got some very important
information to tell you about their
experience the last time they ate at the
Beast truck Madam tell me the experience
what was it like it just in general did
not live up to our expectations and was
not at all what we expected for a beasto
what was the biggest disappointment
across the whole experience the food the
food Andy anything to say nothing to say
nothing anyone else
we were there a year or so ago none of
us can remember the experience we didn't
even know the restaurant was still in
business until we saw I don't really
want to comment MH because I I don't
want to get into it isn't this valuable
information when did you eat up the be
when was the last time um I've beaten
there twice the last time was probably
about a year ago and describe the
experience you know you walk through the
door it's kind of dark gloomy there's no
one in there at all you know and then
you sit down and eat and you know it's
like you have everyone staring at you
when you're sitting there eating you
know it's just a very uncomfortable
honestly deep doubt are you looking for
naked women dancing on the table what
are you looking for hey relax what are
you looking for relax relax relax they
don't want to see naked dancers on the
table come on Andy these are customers
he didn't want to hear about it it was a
wall that Andy had around him but he
needs to listen to what the people are
saying why' you take it so personally
this is really not nice for us so like I
got to suck it up right now it's not
personal yeah
so getting you guys here today was
valuable for me to understand where
we're going wrong I'm sure andell will
take the information in the right text
uh but thank you in spite of Andy again
refusing to take advantage of any
feedback Chef Ramsey pushes on to
another problem in the restaurant Andy's
inability to delegate anything to his
Sue Chef to make his life easier yeah
I'll do the dish with you then tonight
as we're in service Henri can cook the
dish
so is he going to do that dis he's going
to purely cook one Snapper just to make
your life easier whatever are you all
right by the way you don't look very
happy you seem like you've got into a
little bubble again no I haven't okay
great have you cook Snapper before yes
you have yeah good getting on the stove
be nice tonight cooking you know Snapper
dish helps speed up just to get food out
you square it up the fish Cooks evenly
yes yeah and nothing's overcooked on the
outside fish in always lay away from you
yeah skin side down fingers on the top I
wish you had a stove in I could keep
them there my concern was is that I was
going to cook the fish properly and get
it out in time take your fish puy glaze
and sit that on top of your Vine would
you like a little taste first yeah yeah
Ellen please local Co Snapper and more
importantly right now pretty good for
the bottom line in terms of profit wise
that's really good I love the dish it
was delicious hopefully we'll sell most
to the specials tonight and Hendrick
will be taking some of the pressure off
of Andy Andy I know you're busy come
have a little
taste yeah very good hey
[Music]
G very nice happy with that on your menu
that's
fine coming out that ticket is like a
hot potato in your hand get it out the
battle between Andy and Gordon escalates
to a full out war is they wanting more
cook why can't you just cook
it and when the beastro hits its
breaking point it wasn't given to me on
a [__] place so don't throw
away Jeff Ramsey gets devious something
I need to show you very very quickly you
won't believe what he does in order to
get through to Andy I'm so sorry but now
you've overstepped the mark that's
coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares in spite of his frustration
and disappointment with Andy Chef Ramsey
has taken a number of steps to make sure
tonight's dinner service will be
smoother we'll do 10 pors of this stuff
tonight okay Gordon has created a new
tasty profitable Snapper special lay
away from you so you don't Splash he has
insisted that suf hendrik will cook hi
welcome to theist and lastly he's made
sure that both waiters will be taking
orders which are your tables I got this
side with different waiters taking the
order at the same time it's easy to
accommodate customers the whole place
should run as a team we have some great
specials tonight for local cart red
Snapper I'd like to have a snapper you
just had a little tast I finished the
thing off you was so good now that both
waiters are taking orders one of Chef
Ramsey's goals has been realized order
in orders are getting into the kitchen
much quicker full be throws a middle one
Mahi and three Snapper order in one
capacho want a scar order guys heard
heard the only question is can Andy
handle it and order in tell me when to
fire those Snappers Andy not yet because
the duck's going to be a few minutes
what table's next trying to do this one
here I need to fire that Snapper or no
hang on I don't want you fire me being
ready 30 minutes into service and the
kitchen is already behind Hendrick is
waiting on the sideline for Andy to tell
him what to do and Andy is still cooking
one dish at a time Andy what's going on
with tick I'm still missing the M on the
last table that came on order that
ticket is like a hot potato in your
house get it
out waiting on
that just not making sense ell it's not
making sense he'll get it I know he will
I still think Andy needs to get up to
par he can't do everything himself Andy
needs more support back there I need all
the Entre now Alan don't make matters
worse it's bad enough having him on my
ass I'm just saying six has been there
forever this is a joke that's 1 hour 10
minutes now not one entree served he has
a restaurant next door to him and about
to prove a very important
Point how are you good evening busy
night here tonight yeah yeah would you
mind if by order to go no so not it off
I will go for the S tuna okay how long
about 10 minutes thank you very
[Music]
much get
still no on TR can you believe
that well that's 10 minutes this
restaurant on average 75 to 80 minutes
for an on tra let's
[Music]
go ready yes it is excellent does food
always come out that quick yes thank
you incredible
wow that is absolutely delicious there's
somebody else that really needs to know
about this now
now still no on
[Music]
tra 30 seconds oh God something I need
to show you very very quickly out of the
frustration in terms of why food's
taking so
long I decided to do a little experiment
I ran in there ordered an entree tuna it
came
out 10 minutes they are full I'm just
trying to show you what's happening on
your doorstep
we're going to have to have a serious
talk by the way it was
delicious an hour
ago I'm hungry let me know when I need
to send a snapper if you ready can you
just give me a second just so I can get
these out yeah send the Snapper so you
can focus and get quicker out of the box
go go go after Chef Ramsey's constant
prodding hendrik begins to cook I'm
fireing one Snapper go for it tonight
you reclaim your position as a sue Chef
do a good job he'll trust you
more Snapper Snappers at the window and
now that hendrik is focused on cooking
his specials at least some Entre are
leaving the kitchen Snapper for you oh
there we go look at that thank
you yeah the Snapper is really good Chef
ramsy Snapper cooked by hendrik is
getting positive reviews you cook my
fish like this I'm staying home but the
original menu is getting
panned nailed the spp S
came always under cooked man give me the
plate was pink he never Cooks the way
they want [__] sake I'm really
sorry I cannot believe that you're happy
to serve that if they want it more cook
why can't you just cook it I don't need
to tell you big boy this is your
restaurant I'm so sorry but now you've
overstepped the mark
now I would Ser out my
[Music]
dog after another dinner service filled
with customer complaints Chef Ramsey
tries once again to get through to Andy
tonight honestly I was disappointed
because you proved yet again that you
don't give a [__] about your customers
you're in the service industry customer
relations do you want to hear anything
on I have to say about it to to answer
or oh please there's no point you're
just badgering me you don't want to hear
anything I
say talk to me
Chef my name is
Andy isn't one of the problems that the
customers here are different than your
experience of customers in Europe that
is that is part of the truth people
don't here
understand any form of food or service
really and truly but you can't afford to
be a snob I'm not a snob you just told
me you know they don't know what they're
talking about you just said it
yourself you got to come down Peg I know
chefs that would give their right arm to
have their wife at the front the chef at
the helm and a neighborhood Family run
business it's a dream come true for any
chef I wasn't [__] given it I earned
it good it wasn't given to me on a
[__] place don't FL
way you're about to blow it
completely we at that
point we at that point you you've
brought it to
light you've came and you've told us and
you've showed us and you've brought it
to
light you can win if you want to Andy
wipe a slate clean
and start
[Music]
again that's the best thing to
do
tomorrow together all three of us are
going to relaunch this restaurant
tomorrow is the beginning of a new
chapter wipe the Slate
clean good
night with Andy's first real commitment
to change
Chef Ramsey brings in his renovation
team to work through the night to
transform
[Music]
liistro right good morning good morning
how are you how very than how are you
very well thank you how are you great
yeah good you look great now Andy last
night you told me you were committed to
changing this restaurant yes yes good
cuz today's about change yes this is
your new restaurant have a look at your
new sign
oh my
goodness oh that's
fabulous modern legible does it look
nice I love it it's well overdue I love
the sign it seems like easy on the eye
ready to go inside have a look oh yes
let's
go come in M oh beautiful wow this is
great G of the booths oh thank
God in comes this wonderful leather
upholstered wall comfy bonket seating
take a
seat I like this happy happy extremely
happy it's great I I stuck for words
really because it's it's a big change
for us I mean I've been here almost 9
years to see something in just a few
minutes it's like a shock wow oh my
goodness it's great it was great to see
Andy as happy as he is and I'm so
relieved I'm really looking forward to
see see him in the kitchen I think he's
truly capable of change this is the
beginning of a new chapter it's what we
needed that's for sure this is what you
needed and if this doesn't rekindle that
spirit and that level of passion I don't
know what
will Chef Ramsey spent most of relaunch
day cooking side by side with Andy put
your pan yep nice and hot what else you
got left to do for service I'm just
finishing the uh Penta Gordon is hoping
these new menu dishes will be just what
the local community wants right how does
the food look looks great doesn't it
lovely the gaspacho perfect for a hot
Summer's evening oysters local oysters
extraordinary steam muscles I would
order that perfect have a
taste Entre local Snapper big hit last
night it's remaining on the
menu F and faga burger so good it's
quite straightforward and for me the
secret tonight is the
speed I was a little apprehensive cuz
someone else's menu but time for change
and change is better of course we're
happy that is so good now
everybody this is crucial tonight each
one of your tables will play host to a
phenomenal VIP that is going to spread
the word beyond belief over there the
chief of police over there that
gentleman is the City Commissioner over
here we have the host of the top radio
morning show and there also the local
renowned food critic from the newspaper
this is fabulous thank you pretty
excited to be cooking for the VIPs
obviously they have a big poll so I'm
looking forward to hopefully keeping
them happy I want to know why they
haven't been there
before with a completely new game plan
in place so when it comes on you put on
there you just take it right absolutely
beautiful listro is ready to open its
doors and there will be a local VIP at
virtually every table in the restaurant
oh I'm so anxious I'm glad you're here
you are thank you we have great new
summer menu this beautiful comes with
little I'll try the Snapper I'm going to
have the risotto on your recommendation
I'm going to try your Snapper I think
that sounds really interesting Chef Alan
happy yeah he is who is he's like one of
the top chefs in South Florida is he
really he's very very
famous liistro success tonight rests on
Andy's ability to cook you and him have
got to connect now yeah and his ability
to delegate you keep it on the r here we
go you ready y order in PH like Roto a
pork a snap and a burger here you go
guys come
on yes Henrik make sure they're nice
you're going to need fries for Burger
need that right
away come on come on give me give
me check
out burger is for you look at
[Music]
that
that's really good Andy got off to a
good start and customers are enjoying
the new menu very good ordering but back
in the kitchen things are starting to
heat up got to let me know when I can
fire that second Snapper and Andy is
slipping back to his old ways what do we
need chicken risotto lamb burger Andy
yeah you've just gone silent last 15
minutes not saying a word but we're
going as fast as we can Andy don't go
back to the old ways all right that's
all you are doing table 13 no 14 and
five has been called that's what we're
doing don't you dare go to the wrong
table come on hey come on you hold go go
go go
go where's a [__] Snapper I need two
Snapper on the table ready or not coming
with it CH believe that I'll do that you
don't want to send these do you they can
go with these they just go in a
[Music]
window got Andy can we go with these
come here 2 seconds please Chef what the
[__] is going on there this one's more
cooked than noral Chef come here you
minute come here come just just just
just 30
seconds out of the way of
everybody I need two snap on the table
ready or not there it's relaunch night
and the pressure is starting to get to
Andy come on give me that [__] thing
they can go with these they just go in
the window old habits are return turning
and the food preparation is suffering
Andy what the [__] is going on there
this one's more quick than that one Chef
come here you minute just just just just
seconds out of the way of
everybody you can't just send [__] why
now do we do this sorry Chef I mean to
do what why do you have to cook every
[__] order we're just about to serve
two plates of [__] one mushy [__]
useless piece of [__] crap bit of
fish and one cooked the [__] why are you
looking
away talk to me Chef I didn't quite
catch
it there's no excuse Che you were
running around doing everything I don't
get it where's the
standards you're right I admit
her you coming in big eye opener Gordon
Ramsey a mean nasty son of a [__] it's
a lesson in tough love it's a wakeup
call just that I didn't see it right to
the very
end we can't come this far now and Flake
at the end
huh you know what no cuz this has to go
and I spoke to does have to go I'm
really sorry I'm sorry he I'm dreadfully
sorry he works his ass off all night you
look like a star and then look we come
to this you've got more proudness in you
than that you got two Snappers in the
oven there right yeah that's it there
you go open up and talk to him and teach
him yeah yes sure you know what you
could do would be nice if you put the
spinach on on for me and if they're on
all I got to do is put them in the
window that way let's go this time
Gordon has clearly gotten through to
Andy he's on top of the kitchen again
and food is getting to the dining room
quickly
Snapper that's excellent Snapper's
delicious they did a really good
job Gordon Ramsey is very insightful he
knows Andy can cook he knows exactly
what Andy needed he saw the rut that
Andy was in it's been a dream come true
thank you very much
Andy no more customers that's it can we
break down yeah yeah after a successful
relaunch night in a restaurant full of
VIPs Chef Ramsey wants to have one last
word with the owners here's good news
about tonight the
relaunch was a success absolute success
not one plate came back that is
incredible you seriously can
cook but Andy here's my confession to
you there's been many times this week
that you frustrated the hell out of me
you know that right I know and honestly
I finally saw the man I've been dying to
see you C brilliantly well you're a
different man you just got on with it
delegated and pushed them I don't say a
lot and I don't smile a lot but I I'm a
thinker but I appreciate it I really do
without you it wasn't
possible we appreciate it I was real
down in a dump I mean ready to get the
hell out of here but with Gordon Ramsey
being here this week it's made me think
we can make a better life and a better
business here I just can't wait to get
into this new restaurant that we have
what a long way we have come this
week yeah take care of that stubborn
mule
yes thank you well done good
job good night good
night up until tonight's in the service
I really didn't know if Andy could make
this work and honestly I'm still not
convinced he's got everything here to
make this place a huge success I just
hope that his own stubbornness doesn't
get in his way
unbelievable in the months that followed
Andy and Ellen continued to embrace Chef
Ramsay's changes another one another
filet snap a foto away liistro food is
light and fresh and customers are
thrilled delicious okay well I will let
the chef know thank you very thank you
very much and there is no better
indication of
that than listro repeat
business I think g r saw that I was just
doing everything and doing too much and
it was holding me back I'm really hoping
to progress and move on and get bigger
and better Gordon Ramsey is welcome here
any time here's to Leo and New Beginning
thank
[Music]
you